welcome to the program I'm again
starting today with the existential
crisis that the David Pakman show is
facing due to what is being known as the
YouTube advertiser boycott I want to
quickly catch you up and then get to the
latest news over the weekend we learned
that as a result of many threats from
advertisers to on YouTube to poll
funding we have experienced along with
many other progressive YouTube shows a
total and complete shutdown of
advertising if you go to david
pakman.com the david pakman show YouTube
channel there are effectively no ads
playing period on our videos this means
that the videos are making no money it's
not exactly 0 but it might as well be
zero that the channel is making
something like 40 bucks a day ok this is
a fundamental crisis for the show
there's no doubt about it and what is is
stunning to me is that no one has
answers overnight 99% of our YouTube
revenue has evaporated
I wrote to YouTube and I got a bogus
letter back which I'll put up on the
screen for you a complete form letter
basically telling me Oh David there's
many factors that go into when you see
an ad not all videos are monetized the
physical location of the viewer can
impact whether an ad or not is shown
this is the same thing you've been
getting and you can keep it up pat for
people to take a look at this is the
same thing that people have been getting
for years no matter what your question
is about YouTube ad revenue and then
they do link to a blog post in this form
letter that communicates absolutely
nothing of value to us which is a blog
post written by YouTube saying something
like we are reviewing and revising our
ad serving policy to strengthen blah
blah blah blah blah so this is not an
answer so I push back and I said listen
this is a form letter I need a real
answer all of our videos are still
showing is monetized we are not doing
more controversial content we're not
swearing on the show we're not putting
pictures of gore we need to understand
why we are now facing an existential
threat as a result of this and I got a
follow up letter from YouTube and as you
can see here this was slightly better
saying I checked with our
specialists they confirmed that the
fluctuations or drop you're seeing in
your revenue or ads should end after a
few weeks because we are fine-tuning our
ad system to address the concerns here
and they recognize as you can see here
Pat that this can be unsettling long
story short the revenue may never come
back meaning we have to find a way to
replace it and if you look at those
emails - there's just basic spelling and
grammar errors which maybe that's
nitpicking a little bit but it certainly
does not inspire confidence that looks
like an email when I see the way that
I'm being dealt with as someone who has
340 thousand subscribers and 15 million
views a months on YouTube not by any
means the biggest channel on YouTube but
in the top couple of percent for a long
time and we've committed to this
platform to see that I'm getting these
form letters with misspellings and
grammar errors it does not inspire
confidence I read an article this
morning which says that this is a
problem YouTube might be able to fix in
the third quarter of this year which by
the way is about six months from now all
three to six months from now so here's
the situation this is no joke this is
bad shows like ours are in danger this
is a danger that is unlike anything that
we've experienced over the last however
many years we've been doing this and the
problem is that this is all trying to
solve a problem that is actually not the
real problem this entire ad boycott led
to a shutdown of ads over the concern
that too many ads were being shown on
inappropriate content the problem is the
opposite on YouTube the problem is that
no ads are being shown on content that
is not hateful and is actually valuable
to increase the diversity of voices
because as of right now the YouTube
algorithm that determines what is a
video on which we should place ads and
what does video on which we should not
place ads can't distinguish between Pro
Isis ideology and a critique of Isis the
YouTube system currently as we have been
told if you have Isis as a topic
you're not going to monetize that video
whether you are supporting Isis or
saying Isis is a problem here's how we
fight Isis unacceptable and it's not
even necessarily that controversial - it
could be pretty much any topic when it
comes to politics and religion yeah
those are topics that are interesting
you know people want to tune in to this
they have a passion for it and I guess
you just can't even discuss that anymore
it appears as though the term atheism
now is an instant trigger on YouTube 4d
monetization a discussion of atheism
period no D monetized would they do that
further for Christianity or Judaism I
guess they are cracking down on anything
religious but even lack of religion as a
topic apparently is too controversial so
we've been hung out to dry and people
are writing to me saying David it's
gonna get fixed because this is really
gonna hurt YouTube you know it's really
not because news and politics is a small
piece of all of YouTube's revenue and
while this is completely screwing the
news and politics producers like us
YouTube is gonna be okay because they're
still going to be making the billions on
makeup videos and kids cartoons and
people streaming themselves playing
video games and we have a three pronged
approach that we have to put in place we
have to do this okay but if my goal Pat
is for nothing to change as far as the
show we're gonna keep producing five
shows a week distributing them to 200
radio and TV stations podcast YouTube
channel etc but we have to replace the
revenue and I need your help okay
we have a three pronged approach and
there are people who are already
understanding the importance of this so
we had four people Pat sign up at the
maximum membership amount of four
hundred and eighty dollars per year over
the last 24 hours
four people did that here's one caller
who has doubled their membership hey
David it's Jeremy from Knoxville so I
wasn't even aware of the YouTube thing
until you talked about on the show today
I've been a member so long listening to
the podcast that I just I didn't even
know with any of the controversy about
the ads well I just doubled my
membership to man anybody listening just
do it it's so worth it what would you do
without the show yeah it's so important
it's more than just news it's what it's
where to go where should we go from here
anyway David loved the show keep it up
tap shout out everybody love shout out
to Patti yep
and another person saying that they have
doubled their membership as many others
have done hey David this is Tyler from
Western Washington area a longtime
follower and just a recent subscriber
just wanted to to call and voice my
support and encouragement to keep you on
the air saw your video about the YouTube
advertising so I've recently doubled by
a licensed [ __ ] ssin thank you if I am
and just wanted to encourage you to to
fight the fight the good fight we need
you out there Thanks well we're doing it
and unfortunately there are detractors
as I told you yesterday there are people
relishing in what's going on hoping we
go away yet another caller letting me
know that you are the biggest [ __ ] in
the entire world and your news is fake
and you don't know what you're talking
about so why don't you just shut up and
sit down that's why we need to take
action right now okay my goal is to
change nothing and here's how we're
gonna make that happen there are three
there there's three things you can do
right now to help the show okay and I'm
going to talk about all three of them
and this is not some amorphous thing
this is action okay so number one on the
list membership if you are not yet a
member go to david pakman.com slash
membership and sign up the normal rates
are six dollars per month and sixty for
the year if that's too high I get it we
have a discount code it's I voted 17 all
lowercase all one word
I voted one seven hundreds of people
signing up over the last 48 hours since
this crisis started number two patreon
we have launched this we already have
over 100 patrons on patreon if you don't
want to deal with the entire membership
thing if you don't care about perks you
just want to say hey David I want to
replace a little bit of that lost
revenue that you're facing or if you're
a member and you want to do a little
more patreon.com slash david pakman show
this is really easy we're over a hundred
patrons my goal Pat is to get to 250 pay
okay and that's the initial goal and
then when we get there we're gonna go to
500 because we've got to start chipping
away at this thing whether it's 1 2 5 10
100 or $1,000 a month that you can
contribute if you go to
patreon.com/scishow
every time we have a new donor it shows
up this builds momentum people will see
we have buy-in and I predict that the
more patrons we get the more patrons
that will follow because of the momentum
that we're building so whether or not
you remember go to patreon.com/scishow
and lastly if you ever shop on amazon
amazon david pakman.com slash amazon
before you shop that'll send us a 5 to
8% kickback on everything you buy we
need diversity of voices this
reallocation of ad money from YouTube
will go to mainstream corporate legacy
media it will hurt shows like ours we
need your help to fix the problem ok and
and I'm calling out for everybody to
help in any way that you can even if
it's a dollar a month at patreon.com
slash David Pakman show